everyone thanks so much for coming out
today my name is Wes Foss I come all the
way from Canada I did actually grow up
learning French so if you want to try to
talk to me in some french-canadian I
might be able to understand here today
I'm gonna talk to you about a sink oh
wait
and the reason why I want to talk to you
about yes thank you somebody laughed at
that joke can we just take a second to
appreciate my hilarious joke thank you
thank you I want to talk to you about a
sink away today because flow control in
JavaScript it's really hard so how many
of you show of hands how many of you are
using promises in your code day today
right now okay cool
quite a bit I'm gonna go go a quick
review through promises just because
this is the foundation of a sink away
promises in JavaScript are sort of like
an IOU for something that's going to
happen at some point in the future so
this could be an ajax call returning
data this could be accessing a user's
web cam once they hit the allow button
on the little pop-up that shows it could
be resizing an image the point is that
all of these things take time and with
promises we simply kick off the process
and then we move along with our lives we
only come back to that thing
when we need to to deal with the data so
but why why do we do it this way in
JavaScript and that's because JavaScript
JavaScript waits for nobody
it's simply everything in JavaScript is
a synchronous meaning that we kick off
the process and we come back to it when
we have to deal with the data or deal
with the response so let's relate this
to real life something that maybe you
did this morning which you you want to
make coffee you want to drink your
coffee you want to cook your breakfast
and you want to eat breakfast would it
make sense to finish making coffee
before you can even start cooking your
breakfast would it make sense to make
the coffee drink the coffee and then
once you're done then you can go ahead
and and start making your breakfast no
that doesn't make sense we want to
really just kick off the process of
making coffee and then come back to it
and deal with the result accordingly so
how we sort of dealt with this in the
past was something called Christmas tree
call backhaul and we would write code
that looks like this we've all
written terrible terrible code that may
probably got a little bit more it looks
like a Christmas tree if you go on the
side what's really cool about that is if
promises allow us to start writing code
like this where we can run our functions
make coffee make breakfast and they
return a promise not the data a promise
that the data will come at some point in
time and then we can use dot then to
listen for the data actually coming back
we can take it one step further and sort
of wrap it in a mega promise by saying
promise dot all and that will allow us
to wait until both of those things are
done until we go forward and deal with
the result in this case eat our
breakfast and drink our coffee another
example let's say we were building a
little animation library where I want to
do one thing after another well rather
than doing the callback hell on the
table what we can do is kick off move to
which will return a promise and then we
can change our vens whereby returning a
promise from each subsequent one so this
is really exciting because a lot of the
new browser api's are being built on
promises so we've got fetch or you can
fetch your data then that will come back
we convert it into JSON and then finally
deal with that data at the end of the
day we can use a library called Axios
which is really exciting
warehouse um it's kind of like fetch but
it has some really good built-in
defaults where we don't have to have
that second and then change although on
the one there's many many more browser
api's payment requests dealing with
credit card data in the browser
getusermedia getting access to the web
cam web animation api all of these
things are being built on standard
promises it's really easy to make your
own with promises as well so here we
have a function called sleep where it
takes in the amount and the way I
promise works is immediately you return
a promise and then what you do inside of
that promise is you either resolve it
when things went well or you reject it
when things didn't go well so in this
case after 500 milliseconds we're going
to resolve it with some data or if it's
less than 300 milliseconds I'm going to
reject it because that's too fast and
what that will allow us to do is is a
little bit something like this where we
can write our code and then we can chain
then then then on it and by returning a
new promise from each one we're allowed
to keep going in
that code along the way we get it
promises are really really great but the
then not I'm not happy with it right
it's still kind of callback II and any
code that needs to come after the final
promise it all still needs to go into
that final dot then it can't just be top
level in your current function this is
where a sync awake comes in is sort of
saves the day
a sync oh wait is still based on
promises but it's just a really nice new
syntax for working with it so we looked
at this example earlier we went from
call back to promise base well what we
can do now if you look at the bottom
here is we can simply make a function by
tagging with a sync and then inside of
that we simply put the awake keyword in
front of each of those functions and
that will simply sort of pause the
function from running it will wait until
that promise resolves until it moves on
to the next line of code no thenns no
callbacks needed so let's break it down
javascript is almost entirely a
synchronous non-blocking we talked about
that is great
that we can create these experiences
without having to lock up the browser
whenever we do anything but it's hard to
read it's sort of hard to author this
code so if we look at PHP if we're not
using any threads or anything we wanted
to go ahead and fetch two things from
github what we would do is we would
fetch the first one and when that comes
back we would fetch the second one and
then when that comes back we have both
pieces of data and we can go ahead and
use them reads really nice top to bottom
not so great because why am I waiting
for Wes to come back before I go off and
fetch the Scott in JavaScript what we
can do is we can put both of those
promises into variables and then wait
until both of them come back they can
both fire off one after another and then
we can wait for both of them come back
and then we can use the data by creating
some HTML and displaying it on the page
so the PHP is kind of easier to read but
the JavaScript is more performant
because we're not like waiting on
unnecessary things to finish but I'm not
really happy with either so a sync away
gives us sync
looking code without the downside to
actually writing synchronous code so how
does it work first thing we need to do
is mark our function as a sync so you
still keep your regular promise
functions nothing changes with your
functions that was return a promise what
we do now is we create an a sync
function by writing the word a sync in
front of it then when you're inside of
Ana sync function you simply just await
things inside of it so you can either
just await the sleep function and that
will just wait until it the promise
resolved or if you care about what's
coming back from that promise maybe it's
some data from an API then we can store
that in a variable so really it's it's
the best of both worlds let's take a
look at another example here so in this
case I'm sticking it into a variable and
that's another way that we can write it
and here I'm doing the PHP thing where I
await Axios yet and then when that comes
back I'm going to await the second Axio
set that's kind of slow we don't want to
do that right so what we can do is we
can simply await promise dot all and by
passing promise that all our other two
promises we sort of make one big mega
promise that we can await for both of
them to finish so one takes one second
one takes two seconds it's going to wait
the full two seconds before we go on to
the next line of code now that's great
but if you've ever seen any examples
online the error handling starts to ugly
it up so let's look at a couple options
that we can use for actually working
with error handling first option for
error handling is just don't write bad
code and you don't have to handle errors
I'm joking I don't actually do that you
always have to handle your actual errors
really the first option is and this is
probably likely what you have seen
online if you're looking at any examples
it's use a try/catch so just wrap
everything in a try-catch and you're
gonna be nice and safe and the way that
that looks is you have your a sync
function you give yourself a try write
all your code inside the try and then if
anything happens inside of that try you
catch the error in your catch and you
deal with it accordingly
second or third option
is a higher-order function where which
is kind of cool because you can chain a
dot catch on a sinc functions so this is
a little bit more complicated you might
have to come back to these slides and
look at it but let's walk through an
example so I've got a function Yolo
where I don't care about error handling
in this function I'm gonna assume
everything works great then I'm going to
await something that maybe gives me a
404 and it's going to break because no
data came back this could be a syntax
error this could be any error that Axios
might throw you then this is where it
gets a little bit hairy so stay with me
will you create a high order function
called handle error that takes as an
argument the actual function and then
from that you return a new function so
you basically just return the same
function but with a catch tagged on to
the end and the catch that's tagged on
to the end that's where you actually
handle your error if you're a hotshot
and you're using es6 for absolutely
everything you can do it in one line and
then tweet about how cool you are but I
still don't understand exactly how all
of that works so the way it actually
works right when we created our one
function that had no error handling and
then we created this weird high order
function that takes in the function and
returns a new one
then what you do is you just pass your
unsafe function to handle error and that
will sort of create the new function
that still does the same thing but it's
now a little bit safer and able to
actually handle any errors that might
happen inside of that function this is
I've myself I find this extremely handy
in note and Express how many of you
write Express apps
hands up okay probably about half of you
so let's say we've got an orders page
and when you hit the orders page we want
to find the how are the orders for the
user right so if there were no orders
let's let's throw an error but this
could be any type of error syntax or
whatever now normally in Express you
need to call next and pass the error -
next right but and then what would
happen is that route would not render it
would pass it along you
Middleware line and then at the bottom
of your middleware Express would render
out an error page with the subsequent
error code and error message but that's
good but it doesn't really cover errors
that we throw you have to explicitly
call next for that to work it doesn't
handle unexpected errors or syntax
errors or database connection errors or
anything else that has happened along
the line of your middleware so what we
need to do here is we need to catch all
of our errors and pass them along to the
next function we want to pass any error
and pass it along to the next function
so this is where our higher-order
function comes in so I'm going to create
another one of those weird functions
that takes in the function and returns a
new one but in this case I'm just going
to return the regular request response
next function and chain a dot catch onto
the end and the dot catch all it does is
calls next with the with the error that
gets put along to it again if you're a
hotshot there's an error there's one
there you can do in an arrow function
now this is how we implement it we've
got our catch errors function then we
write all of our routes or all of our
controller functions without any error
handling in it and then you can take
your controller get orders and pass it
to catch errors and that's really really
nice because you can write all of your
routes without having to worry about
specifically handling the error in the
exact same way and then you can just
wrap each of your routes in this catch
errors function the fourth option is
handle the error when you call it so
sometimes you do want to handle the
error when you call it because you say
oh this is a special case if there's an
error here I need to handle it in a
different way so it's pretty simple you
make your a sync function called load
data and maybe an error happens and that
when you call it you can just chain a
dot catch on to the end and then deal
with the error however it is that you'd
like to do that fifth option this is
really important if you're writing node
node will soon exit the process if your
promise is rejected meaning that if you
have any code that doesn't
indle an error on a promise the entire
process will exit and then that could
mean your app actually goes down so
pretty simple you just listen for the
unhandled rejection event and then when
that happens you can deal with it
accordingly probably send it off to some
sort of error handling service so that
you can log it and deal with it in your
in your code so I'm really really
excited about a sync oh wait
I was excited about promises but now
that a single wait has come around it's
it's been a while since something
fundamentally changed the way that I my
JavaScript and I code my flow control i
was using a cinco cinco de s the library
for a long long time which still has a
lot of really good use cases but a lot
of my regular flow control has moved
over to using a sync away so here's a
couple tips for starting today first
write your api is in promises so i know
that we can't go and change all of our
existing code that is likely callback
based or maybe you used another promise
library but you can write your new api's
in promises in and you can resolve and
reject from them use a sink a wait for
flow control as we've shown you today
convert older api's with promise of i so
there's a bunch of different libraries
out there and know it even now ships
with something on the you tillage which
will allow you to take any standard call
back based function where the error
comes first in the callback comes second
you can just convert that to return a
promise
rather than having a callback and that's
really nice because if you're dealing
with any older API where you're dealing
with a library that's callback based you
can still use it with a sink oh wait
finally choose an error handling
strategy take a look at the ones that
I've explained here you'll probably need
one or two of them for your actual
application and and implement them into
your actual application so I want to
encourage you give a sink oh wait a shot
I'm really excited about it I think it's
really going to change that the way that
you build your application thank you so
much
[Applause]